To understand how acids react with bases,
we take about 2 millilitres of sodium
hydroxide solution in a testtube and add a
couple of drops of phenolphathalein
solution to it.
What do you notice about the color?
Yes, the colour of the solution turns pink!
The indicator phenolphthalein is colourless
in acidic solutions, but goes pink in
basic solutions!
As sodium hydroxide is a base, the indicator
turns pink!
Now to see how bases react with acids, we
add hydrochloric acid to this drop by
drop!
What do you observe?
We see that the solution turns colourless
again.
So the
colourless base turned pink and then again
turned colourless after an acid was
added.
What does this prove?
We can say that the effect of a base is neutralised
or nullified by an acid.
Does the reverse also happen?
Will an acid be neutralised by a base?
To find out,
let’s add a few drops of sodium hydroxide
back to the above mixture.
And yes, the
pink colour of the phenolphthalein reappears!
That’s because the effect of acid is
neutralised by the base!
So the reaction taking place here can be written
like this:
Sodium chloride is nothing but a salt.
So an acid and a base react to give us salt
and water!
And guess what such a reaction is called?
It’s called a Neutralisation
reaction!
A base reacts with acid to give us salt and
water.
Base + Acid  Salt + Water
In a similar way, calcium chloride is formed
along with water when hydrochloric
the acid reacts with calcium hydroxide!
2HCl + Ca(OH) 2  CaCl 2 + 2H 2 O
Can you think of a more practical reaction?
When we have acidity, our stomach
produces excess acid which is nothing but
hydrochloric acid(HCl).
And this acid is
very harmful for the walls of our stomach…
which is why we get that burning
sensation.
So to neutralize the acid, what we use is
an antacid.
Antacids as you
would have guessed are nothing but bases!
The antacid reacts with the base to
give salt and water.
And that gives us relief!
Base + HCl  Salt + Water